Death comes to us all when we game, presenting
us with anger-inducing Game Over screens and
the feeling of defeat. Sometimes, those deaths
are well-deserved, but others are just plain
dumb, the result of stupidity or simply bad
luck. Oh, and just make note that some of
these deaths can be pretty gruesome and are
not exactly safe for work. Unless you work
as a butcher or something.
Death by Cuccos
We'll start off with a classic. If you've
been gaming for a while, then you've probably
played the Legend of Zelda series. And if
you're familiar with Link's adventures, then
you're probably also familiar with his many
enemies. It turns out, however, that the humble
chicken is a foe that can give even Ganon
a run for his money. Antagonizing a Cucco
can bring down a fowl doom upon our intrepid
hero. Don't poke the chickens. They will poke
back—with a vengeance, and across platforms.
They do not forgive, and they do not forget…
until you leave the village, at least.
Hit and Run
There's a wide arsenal of available weaponry
in Grand Theft Auto V, ranging from small
firearms to the death-bringing Rhino Tank,
and with so many tools at your disposal, you'd
think that the dumbest way to die in this
game would involve some kind of rocket launcher
mishap or a grenade bouncing back, right?
Nope.
Just like real life, it turns out that all
you need to suffer a meaningless death is
to be on the street at the wrong place and
time, because non-player characters have no
problem committing a remorseless hit and run.
This is why we look both ways before crossing
the street...to kill a guy with an uzi.
Waterslide of death
The 2013 reboot of Tomb Raider introduced
us to a young Lara Croft, who was only just
becoming the hardy adventurer we know today.
Lara suffers many hardships and fights against
enemies on Yamatai Island, but no amount of
shimmying and shooting can save her from the
treacherous terrain. Every now and then, there's
a section of the game that has Croft tumbling
down a steep hill or being washed downstream
in violent rapids. If you aren't careful and
fail to steer her towards safety, Lara will
meet an extraordinarily grim end. Look away
now, kids.
"Oh no!"
Maybe just stick to tombs next time.
Overcooked Grenades
Anyone who’s played a first-person shooter
within the last few years should be familiar
with the concept of "cooking" a grenade. This
involves holding an unpinned grenade in your
hand for a bit before chucking it at your
enemy so that it explodes on impact instead
of bouncing around on the ground. Sometimes,
though, players forget the whole "throw it
at the enemy" part. Once you've overcooked
a grenade, chances are that you’re the one
who’s going to be well done.
(boom)
Explosives have a way of doing more damage
to your dignity than your body, as we’ll
see in our next example.
Rocket Jump Fail
The rocket jump is a skill employed by many
advanced players in Team Fortress 2. The Soldier,
as dimwitted as he is, can use his rocket
launcher to propel himself forward by firing
it at his feet and jumping at the same time.
It’s a technique that many players master,
even though it can actually damage or kill
you, either from the blast or jumping so high
that your legs break upon your return to Earth.
Unfortunate players can also launch themselves
over cliffs, which is humiliating, especially
when the game announces that you've fallen
to a clumsy death.
Careless Package
Getting a small killstreak and receiving a
care package in the Call of Duty series is
a pretty good feeling. This incentive gives
players more of a cause to play smart and
stay alive, but sometimes, players end up
being killed by their own care packages, which
are known to drop out of the sky hard and
fast. There are few things more embarrassing
than being killed by your own reward… except
for the instant replay you’re treated to
moments later.
Fire Walk
This one is a no-brainer, but many players
still need to be told that fire will kill
them. In World of Warcraft's dungeons and
raids, bosses usually cover the ground with
fire, acid, or some other kind of goop that
reduces your health. A dungeon run could be
going exceptionally well but quickly turn
into a huge mess if someone isn't paying attention
to where they're standing. A good rule of
thumb is that if it looks like it could kill
you, it probably will, so do yourself a favor
and don’t stand in fire. Unless, of course,
you’re going for the suicidal “Stood in
Fire” achievement, in which case, knock
yourself out. Literally.
Speaking of playing with fire...
Romancing Morinth
One small, stupid, kinda gross choice in Mass
Effect 2 can end your adventure immediately.
As Commander Shepard, you have the option
of trying to seduce any of your crewmates,
including the strange and dangerous Morinth,
who’s kind of like an alien succubus. At
one point, she admits to Shepard that she
absorbs the life force from her lovers and
leaves them black widow-style, empty and dead.
Shepard can pay her a visit and try to engage
in a little intergalactic hanky panky, but
he’ll immediately suffer a soul-sucking
death, which is probably not worth it. Probably.
So just keep it in your pants and save the
galaxy instead.
Impatient Sonic
Patience is a virtue... except when you’re
playing Sonic CD. If you leave your controller
alone and let Sonic stand still for a little
under three minutes, he'll get so sick of
you that he’ll kill himself by jumping out
of the game, followed by some really creepy
funeral music. See for yourself:
"I'm outa here!"
"Yay!"
As far as video game deaths go, this one feels
like one of the most offbeat and unnecessary.
Why couldn’t he just skip rope with his
own head like Earthworm Jim?
Quick Time Events
We've finally reached the bane of many a player's
existence, and the worst of all video game
evils: the quick time event. In Resident Evil
5 and 6, as well as countless other modern
games, you're occasionally presented with
an obstacle that requires you to press specific
buttons at exactly the right time. Failure
to do so results in an immediate death.
The later Resident Evil games are so bogged
down by these unnecessary quick time events
that it's impossible to avoid at least one
or two brutal deaths starring your favorite
zombie slayers. You'll be caught up in a cutscene
and be totally unprepared for the sudden event,
leading to a Game Over and the annoyance of
having to watch the same scene over again
until you get to the part where you died.
Why are we pressing ‘A’ to run instead
of, you know, actually running anyhow? You’d
better train up your reflexes, or you'll end
up reliving your failures over and over again.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know the dumbest ways you’ve ever died
in a video game...